5 25 into Wednesday morning what's
driving me crazy well we do have some
signs of progress in the old Speedway
Bowl remember we told you the other day
about an overnight closure uh where the
I-15 meets the northern 215 Beltway well
the progress we're talking about
involves a different detour than
previous similar closures remember how
they used to send you on the 215 to lamb
you had to flip a UE to get back on the
East 215 for the short trip to the South
15. well the detour that continues now
from 7 to 7 P.M to 6 a.m tonight and
tomorrow night it now involves taking
tropical Parkways off ramp all the way
right across for the slide back to the
15. you just couldn't do that before it
didn't exist now the other sign of
progress is the reason for the closure
The Tropical Parkway bridge over the 15
they're putting in fences to keep
pedestrians safe the Nevada Department
of Transportation says the entire 130 or
so million dollar cluster of new flyover
Bridges and connector ramps is on track
to be completed before the end of the
year buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone you can join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com